In this lesson we learned some new concepts, that can be summarized into five
main points. Point one, our genomes hold
information, and are made of a basic molecule
called DNA. Point two, the basic building blocks of DNA are four different
types of deoxynucleotides, called adenine, thymine, guanine, and cytosine,
or A, T, G and C. Point three:
Long molecules of DNA are organized around
histone proteins into individual structures called chromosomes.
Point four: 3 billion base pairs of DNA are organized into 22 pairs of autosomes
and one pair of sex chromosomes that can be found in the nucleus. And point
five, the total human genome is composed
of elements from our nuclear and mitochondrial chromosomes.